it's harvest season in the soybean field
in southern brazil the city of
prudentopolis is more than ten thousand
kilometers from ukraine but the war
seems closer than ever
russia and ukraine account for nearly 30
percent of global fertilizer exports but
the war and sanctions are hurting supply
chains across the world
[Music]
the question is from where will brazil
buy more fertilizers we have to find
other markets but it's not that simple
brazil is the world's fourth largest
consumer of fertilizers
analysts warn higher prices means less
production of essential crops
farmers are also struggling in kenya up
until recently fertilizing this entire
farm in nairobi cost about 175 dollars
now it's five times as much
like iniquation
with the price hike it's going to cost
about 875 dollars to cover the farm i
can't continue with this business i'm
quitting because the losses are too high
developing countries have been hit
particularly hard by the shortage the
number of people facing food insecurity
has increased over the last year
especially after the pandemic this comes
at a bad time and just ends up
exacerbating our food challenges
globally
in this street market in athens the
effects of the war are already hurting
both suppliers and consumers
i would pay about 20 to 24 for a unit of
fertilizer but now the price is about
forty one dollars and i'm talking about
fertilizers that are essential for us
food prices were soaring before the war
the un says its world food price index
reached the highest level last month
since it started keeping records in 1990
the fighting in ukraine is intensifying
the problem putting at risk future
harvests
katie lopez oblan al jazeera